**Susan Daniels***: Welcome back I don't know about you, but I was kind of doing the CHA CHA CHA on the break I love all this international music and the different genres it's it's very lively i'm thoroughly enjoying the the soundtrack the skills off has.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's kind of pick up where we left off, we have an hour before we break and we're still trying to build a common understanding that's the tasks that we're working with them.
**Susan Daniels***: And we've talked about some of the elements we've talked about what is the Charter we've talked about how do you get a vision was different approaches what goes in the vision.
**Susan Daniels***: So during this kickoff meeting slide I have to share with you that I have been in an array of different companies and kickoffs are done differently at every company.
**Susan Daniels***: So when it comes to any questions relative to the kickoff I would refer directly to your curriculum content not how you used to do it, or how you know it's done from your experience, this is where you're being tested, not on your experience but on what pmi is authorizing.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm sorry you guys some.
**Susan Daniels***: should have sound yeah I should have sound.
**Susan Daniels***: Can you guys hear me thumbs up, I can hear you okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: I get a little a little concerned here there's a lot of buttons and bells and whistles to be clicking on this um if you see me looking at different places.
**Susan Daniels***: Over the course of the week, I have a monitor here to here and one here, plus one over here watching what you guys see so it's kind of a.
**Susan Daniels***: Broadcasting studio going on here, but I digress let's talk about this kickoff meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: What you should know is what are the meeting goals okay and it's really to get people in the room and understand the context of the project.
**Susan Daniels***: Name that's the beginning part whether it's been worked in advance with senior leadership or you're just starting now to do it okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Most of the time, in my opinion, the charters, already been done kind of privately one on one, and then the kickoff meeting so when you start bringing in, shall we say, the supporting cast the people who are going to actually help you get the work done right.
**Susan Daniels***: When you are trying to set the context of the project, using that high level project summary statement and elements of the Charter to help them understand and then they can tell you well you're going to need.
**Susan Daniels***: This kind of support or for this project to be successful, this is what what's going to require so they begin to understand the gap between the current state and the desired future state from their very limited perspective of concern.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, and.
**Susan Daniels***: we're trying to get everybody, regardless of their their perspective in the the organization to all have a common understanding of what this project is to achieve the ultimate objective, the end result measures of success.
**Susan Daniels***: Now this is also saying that in some circumstances may be much, much smaller organizations, this is where we also just kind of begin to set the vision statement we really get it clarified.
**Susan Daniels***: And these things can be fairly small because everyone in the room is contributing to that vision statement and they are helping to define the team charter well.
**Susan Daniels***: How are we going to work well together, often i've not personally seen kickoff meetings and do both the arm the vision statement and the team charter, at the same time, but this is pmi, this is not Allah Susan Daniels or Allah your life experience, so the test questions go per the material.
**Susan Daniels***: This isn't traditional project management or it may be in an agile team coming together.
**Susan Daniels***: This section down here has to do with agile, specifically, I repeat this their user story estimating about for prioritization planning and initial product backlog, these are all steps that happen when you're kicking off an agile project okay and.
**Susan Daniels***: This can be when they're talking about what do we need okay well do we needed all right away what's most like you know what we must have what we'd like to have was good to have okay um and then you start to prioritize it, this is a lot in my opinion, to try to put in one kickoff meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: So you may be throwing questions my directions about how you actually execute a kickoff meeting.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm here to teach you academically which you see on this slide is the right answer, how you run your own kickoff meeting is really how big is your project.
**Susan Daniels***: How complex is your project, and do you need to have like smaller kickoff meetings for different parts of the company.
**Susan Daniels***: Because they have very different concerns right and a whole lot of different questions, then another part of the company, so how to do a kickoff meeting I think is an art okay it's an art form and you learn from experience.
**Susan Daniels***: kind of read the room, if you will read your organization, but this is what it says the meeting goals are and that's likely where the question is going to come from does a kickoff meeting happen, while the project charter is usually in draft or after published.
**Susan Daniels***: This says it can be either way okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: that's just your your team charter i'm sorry.
**Susan Daniels***: that's a good question, because in my world.
**Susan Daniels***: You have to have the Charter before you start getting everybody else involved to be able to start to work on.
**Susan Daniels***: The team formation and getting everyone aligned to the vision, so you have to have the vision, you have to have the Charter, and then you start kicking it off throughout the organization that's been my experience.
**Susan Daniels***: What I think this down here is saying how to do it for agile, this would be for traditional the upper section would be for traditional.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, ensure alignment to the vision you've done all the pre work you've done the Charter and the vision here now you're just communicating it down here you're really just beginning to do an agile kickoff Okay, this is a different approach.
**Susan Daniels***: So the questions, maybe, what do you do in one scenario, what do you do in a different kind of methodology okay there's two approaches, we look at two questions.
**Susan Daniels***: I had this conversation, the other day chicken and egg right, how can you develop the vision right.
**Susan Daniels***: um before the proper analysis of the problem hey so so I agree it's It can be done, read the room, I guess, is what i'm trying to say read organization and figure out what would really work best in your environment.
**Susan Daniels***: I need to move on, because I have several more slides I need to accomplish before we depart this evening.
**Susan Daniels***: So your whole kickoff of your whole project was was was the slide before now we've gotten we're still in agile.
**Susan Daniels***: And now we've kind of built our backlog of features and we understand what priority we wanted to be in and we've gotten on who our team charter is pretty much figured out, who are the players and now we're getting down to was called iteration planning.
**Susan Daniels***: We will get into much more detail and context on day five for agile i'm just exposing you to these concepts we're going to go deep and stay steady on it all afternoon on Friday okay hours of agile just agile.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: iteration planning is when you're taking a sprint or an iteration this brand is usually about two to four weeks in length and you are trying to figure out how much work you're going to pull into that iteration or a time box called a sprint and scrum.
**Susan Daniels***: you're going to review the highest priorities first right according to the product owner, this is what the users need most and first.
**Susan Daniels***: And a lot of it is just the developers trying to understand what the real ask is hey they've got a description called a user story.
**Susan Daniels***: I want as a this kind of user I want you describe what you want, because and why you wanted was the value to you right.
**Susan Daniels***: And you've got these user stories statements and now you.
**Susan Daniels***: understand and asked two questions, what is it that is really going to take so that I can estimate how much work, this is going to take remember an agile, they are self directing teams and you're.
**Susan Daniels***: Trying to make all your teams high performing and self directing so they're going to estimate the word.
**Susan Daniels***: Sit aeration planning is really trying to figure out, given your expectations can I do 123 user stories or wow that's the only user story, I can get done this week right it's a big ass Maybe I should break it down a little or not.
**Susan Daniels***: it's about what am I, bringing into work on during this iteration, also known as the sprint the team has to gain agreement before I can move forward.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just saying to ramses that yes, we can see your name.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm just looking.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, those are just technical concerns Okay, but for the iteration planning to be successful i'll TEAM members have to agree on what will be included in that iteration.
**Susan Daniels***: So you know we were talking about earlier that we're trying to empower TEAM members right and part of that is to give them decision making capabilities and I said we'll touch on decision making techniques later well today it's later.
**Susan Daniels***: There are, these are some of the most common has some of these should seem very familiar with you right, but the first one might not be familiar with you, or to you.
**Susan Daniels***: When you as the scrum master or as a facilitator of an iteration plan, you are going to see when we come to the end if we have agreement okay.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm either on the estimated amount of work or story points that this should be worth worth or can it fit into this iteration or not, you can ask for them without words without everyone articulating their opinions, you can kind of just do a test of how much agreement you have.
**Susan Daniels***: And you just ask you one show me, you know show me a fistfight and if the whole team goes.
**Susan Daniels***: In other words, i'm in complete agreement this this iteration has got the right amount of work i'm in complete agreement Okay, yes, somebody kind of goes.
**Susan Daniels***: Well they've got a reservation and but if everybody else's fours and fives you have enough consensus to move forward, but you might want to ask what their concerns.
**Susan Daniels***: If you see threes twos and no I first means no okay just i'm not in agreement, I don't I don't think that's right okay and it's some way to.
**Susan Daniels***: get a quick read of the room, and I know i've used that expression a lot, but you get good at it as a project manager, what are the the vibes that people are sending off, and can you sense.
**Susan Daniels***: What the level of agreement is, this is a way to be objective about where they actually stand without asking them for a whole lot of explanation.
**Susan Daniels***: On 55 is used quite a bit in agile teams, so I would tie that to agile quite a bit, but you can use this technique in any sort of team to test for consensus.
**Susan Daniels***: Roman voting on this is as simple as the all movies, you know we bought up the idea i'm kind of neutral I vote I voted down okay that's what it means polling you can literally hear everyone's opinion and then ask for the vote okay.
**Susan Daniels***: That can be a show of hands, it can be anything you want, but the old polling is just asking people to vote yes, no maybe you know, I support this, this is the one i'm I want to do that kind of thing now downloading is a very interesting technique.
**Susan Daniels***: On so you've got.
**Susan Daniels***: A variety of work that needs to be done and you're trying to prioritize what to do next.
**Susan Daniels***: But you've got stakeholders with very different agendas okay and let's be honest, the only care about themselves for the most part right what's important to them and their team in the company.
**Susan Daniels***: So they've got a bias, naturally, and they may even have an agenda right to arm, so you don't know people's hidden agendas and you don't know how biased they might be so.
**Susan Daniels***: One way to find out and prioritize without a lot of words and without a lot of discussion is to give everybody, the same amount of points.
**Susan Daniels***: Then, these people can go up to the the items that can be worked on next Okay, this is usually an agile backlog or list of stories that need to can be produced next.
**Susan Daniels***: And of these must haves and we need to do we know the next 20 or all agree that there must haves but which one should we do in the next two weeks.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: People can vote with their dots and they can move their dots across multiple bodies of work that needs to be done.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, all of these are important to them, they can take all of their dots and put them on one thing, and I have literally seen someone be that bias and an open minded to anybody else in the company, but i've seen it done.
**Susan Daniels***: I only care about that and all my my dots are going to go on that, but how do you become to an objective analysis or decision objective conclusion based upon highly subjective in point is still count up the dots and those stories that have the most dots.
**Susan Daniels***: are the ones that rise to the top and priority it is visible is clear how everybody arrived Daddy you witnessed it as it happened, and it is objective so i've used this technique multiple times it's highly effective.
**Susan Daniels***: So these are ways of making decisions Okay, a team that's a small team, whether it's just the people doing the work do they agree or disagree, I mean this injury or marine or you can have it in a large auditorium with multiple stakeholders doing dot voting in.
**Susan Daniels***: His.
**Susan Daniels***: home is more important to vote on priority, then you know but i've also seen it done when you're trying to figure out what gets funded and what doesn't get funded as projects for the new year, you can use dot voting as well.
**Susan Daniels***: But the whole goal of this is to reach consensus right as you set a common vision and build a common vision of your project.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, now the next thing that we're going to talk about.
**Susan Daniels***: is starting the project okay we've got the vision right we've got the objective the Charter we've got our team charter ready to pretty much start really get going on the project.
**Susan Daniels***: And we're going to end today with basically deciding whether it was traditional are agile or hybrid or methodology and we'll pick our methodology based upon the life cycle that you think best fits this project, so the next few slides have a lot to do with lifecycle.
**Susan Daniels***: termination appropriate project methodology methods and practices okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: To do that, you have to have a strong understanding of what the project is about you have to be able to articulate in an overview statement.
**Susan Daniels***: You have to start to develop your implementation plan and you need to have an understanding of the agile practice guidelines which we are going to start to introduce shortly and even more detail.
**Susan Daniels***: I don't think there's a slide on smart objectives if there isn't please make note of smart sm ar T objectives not is it's an acronym it stands for specific, measurable attainable or assignable realistic and time bound.
**Susan Daniels***: Understanding was smart objectives are is what's recommended by pmi.
**Susan Daniels***: on how you write all your objectives you're going to have more of it in your student manual but i'm not I don't recall if there's an actual slide on smart objectives today.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay there isn't but it's something you need to know okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So we're getting started, what do we need to get started well, we have to get started with the business case the business case is, whatever your senior leadership or the organization used to get funding to justify the spend okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: You don't generally write business cases business cases have done before the project starts so when you are starting your project, one of the things that you might need to reference is to ask during the Charter conversation hey could you share with me the business case.
**Susan Daniels***: Most of the time, your sponsors helped write the business case they're very familiar with it thinking shoot it to you after you leave the meeting, unless they have one on their desk okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay hey can be in the arm smart a can be both achievable or assignable it really depends on what source you reference Okay, you need your goals need to be believably achievable I.
**Susan Daniels***: out i'll make a note to talk to you about smart goals, later on, if I don't see them in the deck for tomorrow, so you start out with your business documents your business case right on your charter is going to provide you that overview of your major deliverables okay.
**Susan Daniels***: In basically what what needs to be produced right your major components.
**Susan Daniels***: This slide.
**Susan Daniels***: Your job is ultimately to prepare for traditional project management, a project implementation plan used to be called the project management plan now is called the project implementation plan.
**Susan Daniels***: And because that's the goal right is to implement it right, the goal isn't to manage the project that's something that to do as a byproduct of trying to implement the.
**Susan Daniels***: The arm the project objectives so is called the project implementation plan and what I want you to think of is that it think with three ring binder.
**Susan Daniels***: and think of a three ring binder with multiple tabs down the side.
**Susan Daniels***: And there is going to be tabs for what you need to initiate your project your charter your business case, your.
**Susan Daniels***: team charter there's going to be things that you need to develop your scope your schedule your cost your communication plan your resource plan your procurement plan.
**Susan Daniels***: you're going to need to know how you're going to manage your stakeholders Okay, each one of these would be sub plans or planets little small plans that, all together, the whole three ring binder all tabs included becomes your project implementation plan.
**Susan Daniels***: Your project implementation plan really on identifies.
**Susan Daniels***: What has to be delivered at each stage of your project pay it is really every tasks deliverable or every activity, what does it take to get it done okay that's all part of when you're setting done your project implementation plan.
**Susan Daniels***: here's some key questions to consider when you're trying to figure out.
**Susan Daniels***: On what kind of.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm just looking ahead methodology we might want to use Okay, are we trying to implement it in an existing business environment or something brand new.
**Susan Daniels***: i'm sorry something came up.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: um who's I got distracted by the chat there was some large ones coming through and I just wanted to make sure I was in the loop on.
**Susan Daniels***: communication plan budget plan can eventually be norms know norms are like values or how we're going to behave on your schedule your budget your arm.
**Susan Daniels***: And you schedule in your budget in your the scope that you're going to deliver those become your baselines those become what you are measured and evaluated against and traditional project management.
**Susan Daniels***: But I need I need to stay focused i'm sorry the chats being a little distracted i'm.
**Susan Daniels***: We need to think about the environment we're trying to get our project implemented in.
**Susan Daniels***: And sometimes we can see what we need to do, and start to plan immediately, sometimes we can only see so far into the horizon Okay, and we can only plan, just so far out.
**Susan Daniels***: But as things come closer to us, we can get more and more details, so we call this rolling way planning, where we plan and high levels milestones if you will okay.
**Susan Daniels***: out far but as we get closer we update our our specificity, we lock in the actual scope, the actual budget and the actual schedule that we expect things to be done in Okay, and part of that process is called something called decomposition.
**Susan Daniels***: decomposition and project management is literally taking a very large idea, though desired future state okay and breaking it down into smaller and smaller work.
**Susan Daniels***: packages until you can literally delegate a work package to someone you can't delegate the whole project to somebody that's your job you got the project, but you can break it down to know who to delegate it to so that it is manageable.
**Susan Daniels***: um and then work packages good debt broken down into activities that it takes to produce that work package Okay, you can go down even further, when we get into scheduling.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, let me check them.
**Susan Daniels***: What are some projects some products people use for their project on their projects project plan.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, quite honestly, word documents okay are used a lot for traditional project management with XL supporting the budget.
**Susan Daniels***: And some dance software to help with the schedule, but these are becoming a little more sophisticated we used to use separate tools we call it our project management information system now raya tools.
**Susan Daniels***: Now you're seeing some things integrating Microsoft project great tool, not dissing it in any way is not enough to create a project implementation plan there's no place for your communication stakeholder management there's no place for procurement management or.
**Susan Daniels***: A variety of other aspects of your master plan it's only good for allocating work over time and costs associated with that work over time it's a great tool for that, but is not a comprehensive project management platform my rough project is good for what it does, but it's not enough.
**Susan Daniels***: If you are doing work where you're just managing the various tasks, there is a lot of software out there on the.
**Susan Daniels***: On the market that helps managers know who's been assigned to do what and what the status of each one of these tasks are those are great that's like jaron furlough and.
**Susan Daniels***: Monday calm and teams can probably do that as well, but the master plan Okay, where it all fits together, and you can check everything.
**Susan Daniels***: The best tool, I found so far is to use Microsoft Microsoft be to use a word document to capture and build out upon from your charter outward.
**Susan Daniels***: And then, to put it out on a well organized on cloud platform.
**Susan Daniels***: you'll find budget information here, you can find schedule information here here's my team's information here's my communication information here's all the.
**Susan Daniels***: Procurement here's where I might have my stakeholder different folders for different components of your path your master plan.
**Susan Daniels***: helps people find what they're looking for faster, so the best solution i've seen so far implemented is instead of having one really long document park somewhere just break it apart like chapters and put it in different folders on on a cloud.
**Susan Daniels***: Just just my experience in the field for.
**Susan Daniels***: A long time and know him now.
**Susan Daniels***: In the industry so.
**Susan Daniels***: This is, are you.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, just trying to look at some of the questions okay so i've got about a half an hour to talk to you about the different methodologies and life cycles and if we have time we'll go through some of mastery questions.
**Susan Daniels***: There are.
**Susan Daniels***: The three that we touched on earlier and dial This is where the team collaborates okay and tries to deliver value okay i'm incrementally I mean just continuously delivering value to the company small two weeks four weeks France deliver value.
**Susan Daniels***: predictive plan based his plan the work, work, the plan and give the big tip at the end right here's the whole thing you asked for now we can break that down a little bit into.
**Susan Daniels***: two phases i'll touch on that in a couple minutes, but on the whole it's all about the big to die at the end, so these will work on things that are very easy to to visualize and articulate what it is from day one.
**Susan Daniels***: Maybe not completely articulate and visualize so we'll use a little rolling wave planning, you know get a little more specific, towards the end and.
**Susan Daniels***: This thing of building a house Okay, we know we need a kitchen and bathroom two bedrooms right.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, you can put that in predictive but, as you get closer to working in those components, you can really nail down what faucet features and what light coverage you want right, you can get down to the nitty gritty as it gets closer.
**Susan Daniels***: But, on the whole, you can pretty much map out what it takes to build a house and tracking with me and when it comes to agile, the scope is ill defined and you're going to figure it out as you go.
**Susan Daniels***: And then we can have the methodology of a hybrid using a little bit of both.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so let's talk about predictive.
**Susan Daniels***: Let me see if I just want to take a check on these slides from boulder.
**Susan Daniels***: This This is important okay predictive traditional waterfall approach synonymous really kind of depends on what industry you're from.
**Susan Daniels***: And when you got into studying project management, but all three predictive life cycles traditional approach waterfall approach all interchangeable you need to know that for the exam okay.
**Susan Daniels***: What i'd like for you to put in your nose for predictive lifecycle is that scope is well defined.
**Susan Daniels***: I repeat, for predictive lifecycle if that's what you're going to choose you're going to need a scope that is well defined.
**Susan Daniels***: I know what I want in this House, I haven't figured out the actual handles on the kitchen cabinets are my light fixture covers, but I know that there's a light there and then there's a light switch over there okay um.
**Susan Daniels***: The other thing that she needs to know for predictive Okay, the word cumulus into our final output Okay, a always a massive deliverable okay that end today where you have the celebrations, and everyone comes and balloons and cake is is um is there it's a big victory party.
**Susan Daniels***: When it comes to adaptive and hybrid life cycles Okay, this is when your environment is a little more complex okay it's when the scope is not as clearly defined.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, you might be able to recognize what successes, but you don't know exactly how to get there, or what is going to look like, but she knows success when you see it.
**Susan Daniels***: In your mama's.
**Susan Daniels***: methods are good for when you're seeking to learn something new, or for like research projects Okay, you know that you're trying to cure cancer or that you're trying to.
**Susan Daniels***: enable something to happen, but to not sure what is going to take to get there, but you can define success.
**Susan Daniels***: When you're working in hybrid methods you're going to have a much shorter iterative timeframes you're going to try and approach assess the results adapt Okay, and try again assess the results adapt and try again Okay, those are your sort of your hybrid you keep learning along the way.
**Susan Daniels***: And you have to have the stakeholder involved in a hybrid lifecycle projects or hybrid methods, because they are the ones that are telling you whether it's meeting expectations are truly delivering value that they want.
**Susan Daniels***: um after each cycle that you go through you are looking for feedback on each cycle.
**Susan Daniels***: So I like this slide a lot better than some of the others because it summarizes nicely.
**Susan Daniels***: iterative incremental and agile, these are called adaptive life cycles now.
**Susan Daniels***: what's the difference, Mr Daniels between iterative incremental Okay, and is agile both iterative and incremental it is both okay.
**Susan Daniels***: This looking.
**Susan Daniels***: agile is frequently used in the IT industry is their preferred planning methods in our rows from the it business domain, but it's being used in other industries as well, people are beginning to appreciate.
**Susan Daniels***: The wisdom of agile of not trying to plan it all one and done, of taking shorter looks at it, and then adapting along the way, so let me, let me start here with incremental because incremental is easier to explain so let's say that.
**Susan Daniels***: increment means that you can you can define the scope Okay, but in a smaller delivery let's take building the shopping mall they were going to build a shopping mall on a plot of land.
**Susan Daniels***: The first increment Okay, is that we need to do the excavation work right and we can define where the retention ponds, going to be, and where the.
**Susan Daniels***: berms are going to be for the landscaping and where we're going to put in the parking lot and the drainage for the parking lot we do the escalation were.
**Susan Daniels***: And then we know, the next step is to try to put in the arm the pipes into into to lay the parking lot the foundations right we're not going to pave it but we're going to actually set the building and start to lay the foundation based upon the design of the parking lot.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, in incremental you plan just that increment in great detail, we know the first increment is excavation the second one is foundations, or the arm.
**Susan Daniels***: The groundwork for the foundations and that there might be to lay the foundation, and then we start you know drying it in and putting in the utilities and etc, etc, we can play, we can plan in increments of how we're going to do this project.
**Susan Daniels***: With the nice thing about adaptive lifecycle incremental is that we only plan for that increment.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, along the way, and let's imagine this pose that we find an endangered species which then causes us to move our pond we can't put a retention pond where we we plan, because we would disrupt the habitat.
**Susan Daniels***: scenario, we have to relay the way the Foundation is going to go and where the balls going to sit which direction is going to be faced OK.
**Susan Daniels***: So the beauty of planning the life cycle of increment is that once you get that solve, then you can adapt to that when you start to lay the foundation you haven't committed.
**Susan Daniels***: on schedule and budget and resources and locked yourself in like you would in a traditional where you plan, the whole thing out right and you're wanting down into the to die at the end incremental lifecycle says i'm going to plan in detail this increment and high level plan.
**Susan Daniels***: As I get closer to the next one and allows you flexibility okay an appt appt ability.
**Susan Daniels***: When it comes to incremental i'm changing now to encourage them sorry to iterative iterative basically says on activities are repeated until they are correct okay.
**Susan Daniels***: This is where, in your notes, I want you to think of prototype proof of concept releases okay you keep working on it in till, it is an acceptable product.
**Susan Daniels***: And as you do each prototype you do the prototype, then you get some feedback and you do it on another iterative and you might do your first release.
**Susan Daniels***: you're going to get feedback on that, and you know why now that I see that I know that I need this there's an old expression, because you know when people know what they want.
**Susan Daniels***: People know what they want, when they see what they don't have.
**Susan Daniels***: So we give them something to react to it a first iteration.
**Susan Daniels***: and
**Susan Daniels***: Then they react, and we come back, we collect those requirements right and we prioritize those requirements and we try again so that's an iterative approach.
**Susan Daniels***: Is beta testing part of the iterative process absolutely ding ding ding right answer.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, can you say developing a minimum viable product is iterative on.
**Susan Daniels***: It is part of the agile approach and Angela has both iterative and incremental, which means we are going to do things in.
**Susan Daniels***: increments right, we are going to plan out a two to four week increment Okay, and we are going to plan in detail that two to four weeks of what we're going to get done.
**Susan Daniels***: And then we're going to release it and we're going to get the feedback like we do an iterative.
**Susan Daniels***: And if we got it right great if there's change this needed that's collected and put back into the cycle to be included into the next iteration okay or into the next increment i'm sorry into the next increment that we're going to build out so.
**Susan Daniels***: agile is about incremental and iterative and then it's always responding to change but it's planned in very defined on segments okay just this work for now.
**Susan Daniels***: Much like we're just going to work on the excavation work then we're just going to work on the Foundation, then see how that goes and continue.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, how do you budget for iterative agile projects.
**Susan Daniels***: Oh that's been the you know, the question of the decade basically um what we're finding is there are methodologies that are evolving and greening popularity.
**Susan Daniels***: I would encourage you to research, that there are answers to that question, but the short answer is, you have a certain baseline cost of your team, and you pay for your team, and you know what that cost is and you go well, that team if it works in two week increments.
**Susan Daniels***: and its velocity of work is so many story points and we've got a total product equal to this many story points.
**Susan Daniels***: Then we can say well it's going to take about this, many iterations this may sets to two for two to four weeks to get this whole product done.
**Susan Daniels***: And you can grossly estimate how much is going to cost for this project or the ultimate product to be built that's one method, because it's a very.
**Susan Daniels***: fixed amount for the most part, that your project your development team when you're agile team costs, but there are more creative ways than that definitely worth researching i'm not have time to go over it today okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um.
**Susan Daniels***: Thanks Carl we're really going to go into agile again on Friday um.
**Susan Daniels***: So the next one, I still want to talk about these life cycles.
**Susan Daniels***: agile is both incremental and iterative i'll give you a moment to consume the slide.
**Susan Daniels***: And let's while you're doing that i'm going to TEE up.
**Susan Daniels***: The next.
**Susan Daniels***: Video.
**Susan Daniels***: guys on day one.
**Susan Daniels***: Here we go.
**Susan Daniels***: Project life cycles depend on the project management approach being used let's distinguish between the traditional and agile project life cycles, starting with the traditional approach.
**Susan Daniels***: Traditional project management can also be referred to as waterfall plan driven or predictive.
**Susan Daniels***: In a traditional project lifecycle once the project is chartered the team spends a significant amount of time creating the plan.
**Susan Daniels***: Once there is an agreed upon course of action execution of the project activities will begin this is usually, when the costs and staffing levels are at their peak.
**Susan Daniels***: toward the end of the project, the customer will accept the deliverables and then the project can close.
**Susan Daniels***: The flow from beginning to end is driven by the plan and change is considered an exception to the rule.
**Susan Daniels***: agile project management is characterized by iterations or repeating cycles of planning execution and delivery.
**Susan Daniels***: Each phase of planning is brief and only includes enough information to proceed with a small increment of work.
**Susan Daniels***: At the end of each iteration the project team can demonstrate what they've been working on gather feedback adapt and do it again.
**Susan Daniels***: The flow from beginning to end is driven by the customer feedback and change as welcome throughout.
**Susan Daniels***: The traditional and agile project life cycles are very distinct and there's no right or wrong approach.
**Susan Daniels***: The best approach depends on the type of work being performed sometimes it may be critical to clearly lay out a plan before moving ahead with project work while in other situations, it may be better to elaborate the plan as we go.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, this is the last slide on the life cycle and then we'll conclude today with some mastery questions so.
**Susan Daniels***: The question is i've saw a couple of them in the chat while you guys were watching the video do agile projects ever end right.
**Susan Daniels***: Yes, they do fundamentally when they run out of money Okay, is when they they end or sometimes it's just an ongoing team of continuous process improvement.
**Susan Daniels***: that the company has invested in and they just use agile, as their method to continuously enhance on some aspect of the company, whether it's their IT platform their websites their.
**Susan Daniels***: Their their billing abilities their their in product so agile doesn't always have to have an end Okay, but there is always the end of the iteration when value needs to be delivered okay.
**Susan Daniels***: Stopping can occur at any point Okay, because you just have reached the last point you're going to invest in delivering value to that process or product.
**Susan Daniels***: So they can go on forever or they can end abruptly, unlike traditional projects which generally have a much larger deliverable that is in mind, and you can end it in in.
**Susan Daniels***: An increment I mean you could stop building at any point on that mall but you'd want to leave it at the end of the increment plan so you would know what to transition to and the next increment or phase.
**Susan Daniels***: The question was do you only use on increment in.
**Susan Daniels***: agile, no, you can use increment in traditional as well is called breaking it down into phases, if you will, each increment would be a phase.
**Susan Daniels***: Where you would literally do all aspects of planning budgeting executing executing money monitoring controlling and delivering for that increment.
**Susan Daniels***: But you have a clearly defined scope okay so interview need that for traditional our predictive but you got predictive and you've got um adaptive predictive can have incremental it okay and adaptive can have increment iterative and agile, which uses both.
**Susan Daniels***: Look at your slides it'll come to you, I know it's a lot of terms and they overlap and it gets as bad as clear as spaghetti, but it can be defined and if you'll just take the time.
**Susan Daniels***: To read your slides look at your student manual you'll understand there's various ways to go about organizing the work.
**Susan Daniels***: What I want you to leave with is this takeaway you need to be on the same page as your sponsors on how you're going to organize the work what method approach you're going to take.
**Susan Daniels***: I had been on the witnessing side of a project manager who thought she was going to take an iterative approach to this project, then she would call the meeting and asked to do a demonstration of the prototype.
**Susan Daniels***: Her sponsor thought that she was using predictive plan the work, work, the plan one and done deliver the ultimate at the end.
**Susan Daniels***: The disconnect between what was delivered and what was expected, albeit it happened very rapidly and that that sponsor did not clue in Maybe the time difference was should manage expectations, there was.
**Susan Daniels***: A very, very uncomfortable meeting, though I sat through as they tried to she tried to educate Okay, and this person tried to reset expectations to the approach.
**Susan Daniels***: You want to from the beginning that's why we're doing this and the very starting of this course, the side of the laying the foundation.
**Susan Daniels***: figure out your approach and gain consensus with your sponsors on how you're going to plan organize and deliver the value of your project that's the key takeaway.
**Susan Daniels***: So let's see.
**Susan Daniels***: thought I had chat around here somewhere.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay um what I want to do now is i'm going to finish out the evening with you just doing a couple of mastery builder questions, and if we get through these and we still have a minute left or so i'll take some questions from chat okay.
**Susan Daniels***: um which of the following should be included in a communication plan choose to.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, you should be able to eliminate one of the answers right off the BAT right we're talking about a communication plan.
**Susan Daniels***: So there should be one and it looks like you guys have eliminated it okay.
**Susan Daniels***: The equipment assigned to each team member that would go in your resource management plan equipment or resources so that would go in your resource management plan.
**Susan Daniels***: How and when team meetings are run.
**Susan Daniels***: team meetings have a lot to do with communication so that's likely right this one has to do with resources so probably not likely project charter I don't know it's an important communication document.
**Susan Daniels***: So would that be in my communications plan now think about that one prefer communication approaches with external stakeholders well that has the word communications in it so i'm going to keep that one so here's again how you approach.
**Susan Daniels***: discerning project management p&p the pmi p&p exam prep questions.
**Susan Daniels***: You eliminate the ones that are obviously not the right answer.
**Susan Daniels***: If it's not clearly the right answer but could be the right answer you don't eliminate it, but you definitely jumped towards the ones that are more robustly clearly the right answer.
**Susan Daniels***: Just.
**Susan Daniels***: An example let's move on to the next one, which of the following examples of virtual team collaboration tools choose to.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, well done i've not seen anyone very.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay, so it looks like we got this one now right share task boards, because we very much want accountability and transparency when we're working with virtual teams.
**Susan Daniels***: You don't want anyone who can just kind of ghost out Okay, and therefore even get more isolated you want them to have shared task boards and shared team chat boards, so that everyone can readily connect when needed.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay social media hmm gives you pause that is clearly not the right answer right we do a lot of a collaboration on social media media but it's not really considered a professional virtual management tool.
**Susan Daniels***: Which of the following is a good practice for the use of collaboration tools.
**Susan Daniels***: Okay i'm beginning to see some different answers here, there seems to be a theme, but i've got some people, and if you're choosing between to go ahead and tell me that you're kind of.
**Susan Daniels***: got it narrowed down right if you're not clear tell me it's both of them which to you're kind of trying to decide between okay.
Right.
**Susan Daniels***: So.
**Susan Daniels***: Right is coming through so can good i'm going to go ahead and show is defined team goals and practices before consideration of what tools, the team will need.
**Susan Daniels***: If you go with what they have already used to you might think that they'll be more efficient and that they'll just keep rolling with what they have.
**Susan Daniels***: But she don't know how much better, they could be if you really understood what they needed.
**Susan Daniels***: Just because they got what they got and may not be the best that they to meet their true needs so before you try to select one.
**Susan Daniels***: I wouldn't go for something that sells itself is the best and the highest the most bells and whistles they may not need all that right they'll need to spend more money than you have to.
**Susan Daniels***: But you do need to meet do that gap assessment on what are they got and would it would help them achieve higher efficiency and greater collaboration.
**Susan Daniels***: So you go back to let the team be self directing and tell you what they need.
**Susan Daniels***: Well, we only have a moment left before the arm the end of the course you will be sent.
**Susan Daniels***: an email it looks like Carl is already there, there is a link he's going to ask you to click on that link and provides feedback on today's course.
**Susan Daniels***: Please let me know if I was able to expand beyond what's already on the slides.
**Susan Daniels***: Please let me know if I was effective and helping you how the understand how these principles and concepts apply in real world.
**Susan Daniels***: And if I was able to share with you in a an engaging way, please give me some feedback and some coaching I will be joining you tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock and will continue to talk about how to get your project started.
**Susan Daniels***: i've really appreciated your engagement and the chat and your contributions so so thank you, but I would be remiss if I didn't think Carl.
**Susan Daniels***: For all of his support behind the scenes, so in your survey, if you want to give a thumbs up and a shout out to our mentoring team for all their support this morning and for the support of the team.
**Susan Daniels***: This afternoon yeah thumbs up to those guys, I think there was um we may have more than Carl behind the scenes is is going a little fast, for me, but I want to thank you for your attention and engagement and I look forward to getting your feedback on the survey take care and good night.
**Susan Daniels***: Cod um you want to throw that on link in one last time, so they can grab it and complete the survey i'd really appreciate that.
**Susan Daniels***: i'll see you guys tomorrow too and you're welcome, thank you for all your words of encouragement.
**Susan Daniels***: And can we have the link, one more time and the survey link, one more time and there we go.
**Susan Daniels***: boy I went fast, but you can scroll up you guys and you can catch the link by just scrolling up on your chat right, you know, and I will see you all good night from my part of the world, and I will see you tomorrow morning 10am Eastern time.